hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Aristophanes is a
comic playwright that means that he's a
writer of comedies and in particular of
what we're called old comedies in
ancient Athens old in the sense that
they were the ones that that first arose
out of the satiric plays and you know
later on a new comedy would replace it
but new comedy was a little bit more
polished a little bit more refined but
not quite so funny and the tale that
Aristophanes is going to tell as his
contribution is in fact a little bit of
comedy within the heart of the symposium
he's playing up to his own arc his own
skill and he's going to tell us a story
that has you might say allegorical
significance but he's actually spelling
out for us exactly what it's supposed to
mean he's telling the other participants
I'm going to relate to you a tale which
will reveal to us the true nature of
love the true nature of Eros the true
nature of designer and the story begins
you notice I've got this little you know
strange looking creature drawn up here
the story begins with the original state
of humankind
like I put here human beings originally
which means that we're not real human
being
in the sense of being original human
beings human beings originally had a
different structure to them a more
complex structure than we had with our
current frames they had one head okay
that's similar to us but they have two
faces and they had four arms and four
left so I've depicted that here you know
I'm not an artist so obviously you're
gonna have to do a little bit of
imagining with this there's videos that
you can see that do that and they would
roll around you know they have their
four lives and their four hands and they
would they would roll all over the place
they're quite powerful as a matter of
fact they got so big for their britches
that they started making trouble for the
gods themselves and so Zeus has to
figure out what to do you know the gods
like the fact that they're getting
sacrifices from the creatures when the
creatures are behaving properly but
these creatures are also causing trouble
he makes reference to a old myth about
about these giants trying to storm
heaven and Zeus you know knocking them
down at the lightning bolt so it's for
um there's there is a kind of original
sin in here now to the Christian sense
and not even in the the Italian you know
Promethean sense but a different kind of
thing it's for hubris the original human
beings are a little bit too powerful a
little bit too similar to the guys and
so like I said they get too big for
their britches and the gods saying we
need to take them down a notch and so
how are they going to do that well Zeus
comes up with a plan we'll cut them
right down the middle and then we'll
have two creatures you know one face two
arms two legs they can get around quite
well but they're not going to be so
powerful as to cause us trouble and that
way we can get twice as many sacrifices
that's going to work out as a side
benefit and then there's even at this
camp part of the funny thing if they if
they still won't behave then we'll tell
them we'll split them again and they'll
just have to hop around on one foot with
one arm and presumably
you know maybe one half of the face or
something along those lines now you know
things don't work out at first because
these creatures just go looking for
their their other half and we'll talk
about the meaning of that you know the
way that they're split isn't going to
really you know work out for them well
so so Zeus has them you know remade you
might say he has the the neck turned
around and the things straightened out
and he has all the excess skin well you
know yeah excess skin but also he has
the the gap the giant chasm within them
covered up with you know what ends up
being our navel he he hasn't pulled
tight right and the other question is
what are these human beings going to do
and we're going to talk about the sexual
relations that happen with this in the
next video which is talking about the
three sexes but I'll just hit on that
here you know you notice I didn't put
any genitals there but Aristophanes says
what do you have three different kinds
of being you know one kind he had both
female genitals one he had two sets
actually a one he had two sets of male
genitals and one he had one of each and
so when you kind of been here you know
like if it's if it's male and females so
here's a female half here's a male half
if it's two two male organs then you
know kind of a half to get two men right
and and same thing with two women
now what's what's particularly important
about this myth is that each half is
desiring unity with its other half but
think about this a little bit now it's
not saying that you know the way that we
often picture it to ourselves that we
are looking for our soul mates the one
you know put in quotes or in capital
letters for us the one who we think is
going to fulfill us we go around as a
single being looking for another single
being and if we have any sort of unity
or communion or intimacy we still think
of it as to that
somehow become one what Aristophanes is
saying is that no they are not simply
becoming one they are being restored to
a previous unity that in a certain sense
none of us are actually complete human
beings that we lost our original nature
with that splitting down the middle now
of course this is a story so it's not
meant to be taken completely literally
you know it's not like you know each one
of us had a Siamese twin when we were
born and then the physical process
happened where we are cut in half and
we're looking for that Siamese twin this
is an allegory right but each half
desires a unity of the sort that we've
talked about with its other half now
that doesn't mean that you know if the
other half dies that they're totally out
to sea because they can look for
somebody who's like that so if it's a
female male original being and now you
know the female half after their split
off dies this male half will go around
looking for other females that are
similar to that that female half it
won't be completely happy with that
because it's not total unity but you
know it's better than than nothing right
and it's same thing you know goes for
everybody else now what is the main
point of all of this an allegory is a
story that tells us about some sort of
deeper truth so what what Aristophanes
is saying the nature of love really is
and what everybody else is missed is
that it's a desire not just for sexual
Union although sex is one way to put
together what has been separated you
know we make jokes about the beast with
two backs in this case it would it would
literally be putting together the beast
that has no back though the human being
the fully human so sex is a way of doing
that but you know like Henry Miller is
observed you can't have sex you know all
day long you come to two other things
and sex is really just a portion of this
desire it's also for intimacy and
compared
in ship he talks about the two halves
wanting to when they find each other
wanting to spend all day with each other
and if you think about what it's like
when you become infatuated and what they
often call you know the honeymoon stage
of relationships people don't want to be
separated from each other
at all because they're so happy about
finding their there's what Aristophanes
would say there's so happy about finding
their hitherto misser yeah up to that
point missing half that now they can be
in total unity with unity not just in in
you know romantic terms or sexual terms
but in a living day-to-day with each
other is sharing in everything terms of
perspective terms of communication this
is not the the be-all and end-all of it
though he says that if have faced us the
you know the God of iron working and
smithing and all that sort of stuff were
to show up and ask these lovers would
you really like me to take the both of
you and melt you into one they would
realize that that's what they're really
desiring they want a fusion into unity
why do they want that because that's
what they originally had and that's what
was lost through this a ridge in a sir
that's this primal transgression that
was punished by the gods so all of these
other things that we think are you know
of primary importance to us having sex
spending time with the the beloved all
those things are really just shadows of
a greater possibility of greater reality
of a unity which would in many respects
fuse the two people into one